do another edition of football pod
america liam mchugh with tony dungy
rodney harrison mike
florio it's a football pod but tony
let's
start with a little baseball your tampa
bay rays
they're out they lose in the world
series the dodgers la
is the sports town right now uh
l.a dodgers played a great series and
we did as well as we could do i'm not
sure
why we made our pitching change i'm
still trying to figure that out like the
rest of tampa but
uh ray's had a great year and we're
proud of him
hey you got the stanley cup right you go
to the world series
you still have the tampa bay buccaneers
and we're going to be talking about them
tom brady antonio brown
were you talking about the best matchups
in the nfl this week but believe it or
not we're going to start
with the cleveland browns off to their
best start since 1994 they're five and
two
but of course going forward they're not
gonna have odell beckham jr he's got
that torn acl so he's out for the season
you cannot question his talent but i
think if you look at what the browns
do offensively and you look at their
schedule going forward
mike gloria i'll start with you how much
does this really change for them
well you know i know odell beckham jr is
a great receiver now maybe his best days
are behind him
but there's been that constant pressure
that stress to get him the football
and it's always a question especially
when they're not winning and it just
seems to be a burden on quarterback
baker mayfield look how well we played
on sunday without obj
you look at their schedule you look at
the games they have coming up
this is a team that can win 10 or 11
this year now they may not be ready to
win in the postseason
but for a team that has been as bad as
the browns have been for
basically the last 20 years this is
progress
and i think they'll conclude after this
season they don't need otto beckham jr
and he'll be somewhere else in 2021
mike i agree with you and and when i
look at baker mayfield i just look at
the mental toughness
that he showed not allowing that injury
to ruin his day he comes
and he throws five touchdowns but also
his you know he has an
opportunity now to continue to develop
that chemistry with those young wide
receivers those tight ends
so if they can continue with that run
game i'm not sure if i still trust
um baker mayfield if they don't have a
run game
but you know just developing that
chemistry with those young guys i think
that's going to help out coach
it will and the browns no question
they're going to win with running the
ball playing defense and mayfield making
plays
but taking away great players isn't
always good and odell beckham
when they load the box against cleveland
he still is a threat against one-on-one
coverage they're gonna miss that
eventually
uh is it a death blow no i don't think
so because they've got a lot of other
talented
players but there's gonna come a time
where they're gonna wish they had odell
beckham running against one-on-one
coverage
yeah you feel like that time will be if
and when they make the playoffs i think
mike makes the point that you look at
their schedule right now
i mean it's hard really not to see them
winning 10 games this season i mean the
schedule definitely sets up that way
mike mentioned it but for tony rodney
and tony i'll start with you
do you think this is it for odell
beckham jr in cleveland
not necessarily um you know he
serves a role i think he's a good player
i think the team
likes him and gravitates to him we'll
see what happens
obviously if they go on and do win those
11 or 12 games and
end up being in the playoffs then it'll
be a money decision but i hope odell
comes back because i think he does bring
something to them
yeah coach i agree with you i think he
brings a lot to him but the problem is
when odell comes back
typically coming off an acl it takes you
two years to feel like yourself
and that next year when he comes back
he's not going to be 100
he's going to be frustrated the fan base
is going to be frustrated at him
so eventually i agree with mike florio i
don't see odell being in cleveland next
year
that's going to be the challenge though
trying to trade him
what value is he going to have when is a
team going to be willing to pull the
trigger
i it's it's a it's a real risk because
he may never be the same we've seen that
happen to guys
and it's going to be a long road and and
the the way the calendar works out for
next season
he may not be even close to 100 by the
time some decisions have to be made
yeah brown's the longest active playoff
drought browns hostel raiders on sunday
now we have the eagles and the cowboys
on sunday night football but next sunday
november the 8th we're going to be down
in tampa we have the bucks against the
sink for what will likely be
antonio brown's return to nfl action
all right you look at this box team all
right so they've
certainly found their chemistry
offensively it's a team that's on the
rise the offense has put up was it 83
points just the past
two weeks you'd have to say one of the
top defenses in the nfl certainly
a stout run defense bringing in antonio
brown
at this point tony is this the right
play
and do you think it's gonna work well as
a bucks fan i'm concerned
because i saw rob gronkowski after a
year off and all the first half of the
year rodney we were saying what's wrong
with gronk what's wrong with gronk
what's wrong with brady they don't seem
to be on point
they're going to go through the same
thing with antonio brown it's going to
be six weeks of
getting him into the flow and getting
adjusted now is that going to take away
from the rest of the group i'm not sure
that that would be my concern right now
and coach and coach he must be willing
to accept his role whatever that is
come in and say you know what i'm
willing to do whatever it takes to be
part of this team i don't care about
individual accolades i don't care about
numbers i'm not trying to set myself up
for next year's contract if he can come
into that system
and be that type of teammate along with
all other teammates and put himself as
equal
amongst everyone else then i think it
can work but if he
goes and if after three or four games he
only has seven eight catches and he's
not happy
he's going to ruin that team and that's
an excellent point rodney because the
way his contract is structured there's a
lot of incentives tied to
production 45 receptions over the
balance of the season 650 receiving
yards six touchdowns
if he's not on the field as much as he
wants to be on the field if he's not
getting the football thrown his way as
much as he thinks he should
then it's going to be a problem he's
going to get frustrated will he be able
to
contain himself and to coach his point
the last time we saw this guy play at a
high level
was against the saints week 16 2018 he
had a huge game
that was the game where juju smith
schuster had the fumble that cost the
steelers the game
cost the steal as a playoff spot two
days later juju's miss schuster's the
steelers mvp
antonio gets upset and that was the pin
in the grenade
that that is still exploding for antonio
brown
two years later and he's hardly played
so what is he going to be
i don't know and i don't think the
buccaneers really know and whatever
happened with him and tom brady for two
weeks in new england last year must have
been powerful
because brady believes in this guy at a
time when no one else seems to
but but take a look back to week one
two three and four in the buck season
and ball's just going off gronk's
fingertips and
balls just going off mike evans
fingertips and
we're saying what's wrong with brady he
doesn't look good well now six weeks
later those
those are strikes but it's going to be
the same way with antonio brown so he's
in there
and the ball is just off his fingertips
well what's wrong with antonio and
you know it i can see all of this going
on
while they're trying to get him going
does it cost them some games that's what
i'd be concerned about
but but you know what coach the one
thing about it i just looked at tom
brady and his leadership and his ability
to keep
antonio brown kind of just honed in and
focused and and
you know i think they've had
conversations bruce arians come out and
say tom had nothing to do with
antonio brown coming i don't believe
that i believe that tom had a big
role in him coming to tampa tom is a
very unselfish guy
he takes time with each individual
teammate
and i think if if if antonio brown
connects with tom brady and stays
within his presence i think he'll be
fine but if he gets off to selfish mode
he starts doing things
on his own limb then forget about it
he's going to ruin that locker room
one more point because to a certain
extent the buccaneers are selling their
souls with antonio brown
this is a guy who still has he's got a
pending sexual assault civil lawsuit
that's due to go to trial in december at
some point he's going to be questioned
under oath in a deposition
he does not do well in that setting and
they know that they know this going in
they know the nfl is still watching him
they're looking at whatever evidence
that case generates
and then this could create a huge pr
problem for them later
there are people who don't feel good
about the move now
and and they they but hey they've
already put all the chips in the middle
of the table now they're throwing their
watch and their car keys on top
to try to win a super bowl but mike let
me just say this not necessarily because
it's not like they're
they're paying this guy they guarantee
them 10 15 20 million dollars
isn't it a one like a one year contract
a million dollars is the base salary
i think i was reading that on your
website right so it's not
but it's about what it does to you as an
organization it's it's not the money
it's it's it's doing business
how quick but that's my point
that's my point
no matter how quick the hook is you've
already made the decision
i came down on the patriots last year
when they signed antonio brown saying
hey you know what
this we you can say all you want about
equality and women's rights and caring
for the community this this is all about
a super bowl
and that's what it is for tampa and
that's the feeling down here people are
excited the football fans are happy
people are saying what does this do for
our community there's some unrest here
already
but also let me just hold on liam hold
on
if if antonio brown comes in there and
he does something crazy that bruce
aarons
doesn't like then it also puts bruce in
a position where he can release this guy
but it also sends a message to the rest
of his team saying look yeah we brought
this guy in but if you're not the right
type of guy
to be part of this locker room we're
going to get rid of you so i think
i think in this situation i believe that
antonio brown you know
he does deserve another chance but if he
doesn't make it
work he's going to be gone
listen there's a lot there just the idea
that there's going to be an adjustment
for weeks
for antony brown potentially that could
be a problem you obviously have the
trial in december
so here we go raise your hand right now
if you expect
antonio brown to finish the season as an
active member of the box
i
all your betting is your hand just your
hands hold my hand okay i'll raise my
hand
you use you use your off hand
rodney mentions bruce arians making the
call to get rid of him you better make
sure tom brady's on board with it before
you get rid of him that's part of the
problem
you've empowered tom brady he better be
okay with it before a b
has run out the door and i don't think
he was okay with it when the patriots
cut him last year
okay so mike florio ready to bet the pft
compound
tony just the left hand
rodney a coach is willing to bet the
mansion in tampa
well that'll be the bet because he can
move out of brady's house and he'll move
into that house if it doesn't work out
so all right let's focus on a few key
matchups because obviously we're going
to see
tampa bay and the saints in a couple
weeks but few key match-ups for week 8
and let's start with an afc north
showdown we have the steelers the last
unbeaten team in the nfl
they visit the five and one ravens all
right rodney i'll start with you
your initial thoughts on this matchup
my initial thought was how will um
both offenses handle the pressure and
all the different looks that they get
and i'll tell you this man just watching
pittsburgh defensive film we sit back
and we watch tj
watts and bud dupree and cameron hayward
we give them guys props
but you look at linebacker vince
williams he's playing as
as well as anybody on that defense and
that's the name that you don't hear very
often
and i think it's all going to come down
to lamar jackson uh you know mike tomlin
that group that
hey let's load the box the running game
lamar's been on
on several games and they've looked
great there's been some games where he's
been just a little bit off and they've
struggled
they're gonna put it in his hands to
throw the ball he's gonna have to throw
the ball to win this game i believe
and literally my first thought when i
hear steelers at ravens is the old heinz
ward story about the bus pulling in
and getting three generations of middle
fingers from ravens fans when they'd go
to baltimore
but you know to rodney's point on vince
williams
look at the hit he put on ryan tannehill
down near the goal line
in the first half of sunday's game the
steelers deal with mobile quarterbacks
in a very direct abrupt and violent way
now first they got to catch lamar
jackson
but i guarantee you you know they did
the carson wentz
they did it to ryan tannehill they're
going to look to do it to lamar jackson
if you're going to decide to run the
ball you're no different than any other
running back and we're going to come hit
you
as hard if not harder than a guy who
normally carries the football beyond the
line of scrimmage
and tony back to you i mean we saw we
didn't see
that tennessee they came the titans come
out and they did score in the second
half of them
but is this all about throwing the
football because if it is this is a
passing offense that right now
only the jets have a worse passing
offense in the nfl
well you know mike tomlin knew last week
i've got to stop derrick henry
and i'm going to sell out to do that and
they did in the first half
ryan tannehill got some things going in
the second half they're going to come in
and say you know we got to take the
running game away we can't let lamar run
the ball
we'll do some things and there's going
to be some things open in the passing
game but he's got to hit them
and i think that's the way the game's
going to go if lamar hits him i think
baltimore will have a big day
rodney one last thing for you because
obviously we spoke about antonio brown
and
the ravens they signed dead brian to
their practice squad we're not going to
see dez
at least for a little bit do you think
dez bryant has an impact on this team in
the passing game going forward at some
point
if if if i was a team and i was
preparing against
dez bryant i wouldn't really be
concerned i just wouldn't i mean he
hasn't played
football in years he wasn't the fastest
and you talk about years later
him coming on the field i don't think
these young guys are afraid of dez
bryant he doesn't carry the same
reputation that he
now that he carried years ago when he
was a stud
let me just say one thing about dez
bryant because i believe very very
strongly this is the truth
dez bryant is the guy that the ravens
initially flirted with
and then signed to the practice squad to
placate the guys in the locker room who
wanted antonio brown
period that's why he's there and i don't
think he's going to be there very long
all right so he may not be that big of a
help to a team that let's face it if you
look at their receivers they rank dead
last in the nfl receptions and receiving
yards
and to rodney's point dez bryant has not
played the game since december
of 2017. let's stay in the afc let's
take it to the east division that's
let's
be honest this century has essentially
been owned by the patriots
the pats however they are two and four
they're coming off that ugly loss to the
49ers they visit the five and two bills
tony you would look at the record and it
obviously
suggests that new england is under a lot
of pressure
but this seems like it is enormous for
the buffalo bills
i'm with you liam i think the bills are
under so much pressure
if you don't beat the patriots now when
are you going to beat them
so josh allen bill belichick we know
he's going to take away what the team
does best
we know that the patriots are going to
run the ball against buffalo
it's going to be on josh allen and
you've got to perform you've got to win
so
i think this is a huge huge game for the
buffalo bills
and you know what coach i think the
patriots despite everything and how
poorly they look the last three weeks i
think they're going to come in with a
lot of confidence
because they have a lot of familiarity
with the buffalo bills
they play in the division they know how
to stop josh allen from running around
and scrambling around they still feel
like they have the dbs to match up with
those wide receivers
and then you look even on on the
patriots offensive side of the ball
you're not afraid of buffalo's defense
you saw what happened with kansas city
kansas city ran
up and down through buffalo's defense so
if you're the patriots as poorly as
things have gone you still have
confidence that you can
that you can play well and compete and
be buffalo
i think the key guy to watch on the
buffalo bills offense is stefan diggs
because we've seen some flashes of
frustration and that was characteristic
of his time in minnesota
one of the reasons why they weren't all
that upset about moving on from him
because there were moments
where he he's not involved the team's
not winning
and it becomes an issue you know late in
the kansas city chiefs game he's walking
back slowly to the line at a time when
they should be trying to get to the line
and get moving
i saw some body language last week
against the jets when it wasn't going as
easily as it should have
if the patriots take him away and
frustrate him and they can't get him the
ball
and the patriots are winning just keep
an eye on stefan diggs because
i that could be the tipping point for
that team to lose the game to the
patriots
but you know what mike i'm also gonna
look and that's an excellent point you
make i'm also gonna look at kim
and my question is when you know and
this has been my question since
cam came to the patriots when once he
faces adversity and this is adversity
how will he deal with
it now will he come out sunday and he
talked about possibly losing his job
will he come out and play aggressive or
would he play come out
timid trying to protect his job so i'm
really interested in looking at how cam
newton plays
and his mindset
and rodney back to you if cam doesn't
play well the pats fall to two and five
where do you think they go from here
i just have to see how the game plays
out if the game is on cam
then you might look to bella coach
belichick to make a possible change
what do you think coach you know i
i think cam's going to play well because
i think they're going to run the
football and that's going to set up a
lot of things for them
i i really i'm looking at the other side
i know how the patriots are going to
play the patriots are going to play a
good game i want to see
if buffalo comes with their a game yeah
i i got to tell you i i went to school
in buffalo i lived in buffalo for four
years
i i can almost feel the tension and i'm
all the way down
state in new york right now this is a
place that for so long
expected nothing to go right and that's
the bills and the savers guys
now the bills are good and having hope
sometimes because a dangerous thing for
a fan base because you're nervous going
into big games like this
all right let me move on to 40. what i
bet you're a steak dinner
my pets are getting your bills all right
we'll do the steak dinner
at tony's house which he's also betting
we'll combine all the vets into one
gigantic there you go the 49ers
they crushed the pats last week they
visit the seahawks on sunday 49ers at
this point
lead the world in high ankle sprains
they are depleted at running back
but mike florio kyle shanahan
and his team have bounced back from
those back-to-back losses to miami and
philadelphia
it looks like he has got a plan what do
you think of the job that he's done
what a turnaround after getting blown
off the field by the dolphins 43-17
i thought they were done i thought it
was over they were starting that
seven-game stretch
and they're two-and-oh so far they beat
the rams in prime time they beat the
patriots in a big spot now this is their
opportunity to go back to the place
where
they nailed down the one seed last year
but it's a very different team
and this seahawks team you know the fact
that the seahawks lost on sunday night
is going to make it even harder to go in
there and beat them this is a high
stakes game for both teams
all four teams in the nfc west are great
this year and kyle shanahan
is showing that he really is and i've
been saying he's got the potential to be
the next belichick
what he can do with whatever he has
however many guys are injured
however many guys aren't his usual
starters just plug the next guy in and
we make it work and the way that offense
works with whoever just happens to be
hanging around it's incredible
and coaching i don't know what's going
to win this game but i'm going to
predict the score rodney 100 to 99
because san francisco has no pass
rushers they've stopped russell wilson
in the past
by rushing the passer they have no pass
rushers
wilson's going to have a big day the
49ers are going to run the ball with
whoever they put back there they might
put
george kittle at tail back they're going
to run the ball and pound this
seattle defense so i don't see anybody
stopping the other side
i do believe that jamal adams will be
back he told me that
there's a chance that he'll be back this
week and he'll be that guy spying on
cala murray
but i agree with you coach and you said
this a few weeks ago you talked about
kyle shanahan
and i look at what he's done i i mean
right now to me mike florio he's leading
as far as coach of the year what he's
been able to do with all the injuries
the east coast games like you talked
about
beating on coach belichick they hadn't
been beat at home
in x amount of years i just kyle
shanahan has been
absolutely terrific and that was a great
comparison because he is probably the
smartest youngest hottest coach out
there right now
total points i'll let out michael's now
i think that'll be over
for the week take me over but tony i do
want to go back to you because we talked
about this a few weeks ago
this is again and we saw it sunday night
this is seattle kind of living
dangerously
it makes for thrilling games and but you
gotta wonder i mean
can you really can you win it all
playing like this
no you can't you're living dangerously
every game comes down to the last
possession you you hope to score on the
last play or stop the opponent on the
last play
you can't do that week in and week out
seattle has to play perfect they've got
to minimize their penalties
uh russell wilson has to be on point
every single play
so i just think you're you're going to
see
this happen to seattle and they're going
to play exciting games they're going to
win their share of them
but in the big games that that lack of
stopping people is going to catch up
with them
yeah you just don't they don't have pass
they don't have pass rush i mean
you can't get to the super bowl and win
the super bowl without pass rush
rodney i just have one final question on
this game for you if i gave you a
15 yard lead would dk metcalf
run you down before you hit the end zone
now at 47 yes but back when i played
heck no buddha baker is slow and you
know it's slow
mike florio you need to pump him up for
possible defensive player of the year
but he is slow he's only 195 pounds
and he gets caught behind by a wide
receiver come on coach
that was a great play i i i don't know
what to say about that you usually don't
see that although
we did see benjamin watson catch champ
bailly the same way um i think there's
something about competitive guys that
just aren't going to give up and that
that showed me a lot from dk
but remember coach remember when he was
on an end zone and it and
remember that the db knocked the ball
out of his hands
he learned from that so that's something
that he needs to do coaching
that's exactly what he learned you're
right and you got to admire it when a
guy on
offense flips to a defensive player and
goes after
the the guy with the ball because
there's a real risk that's what happened
to odell beckham jr to take it all back
to where we started
he was hustling after a turnover and he
got himself uh knocked out for the year
yeah but you guys got it
yeah you were talking about antonio
brown dk metcalf in that game was not
having a good game patrick peterson was
on it not a lot of balls coming
he catches a guy a hundred yards from
behind and then in the second half on
carlos
hyde's play he gets a great block on a
defensive end he's excited because he
got the block to spring the touchdown
that's that's the kind of attitude you
want from all your players but
especially your receivers
and coach to think about it my patriots
had a chance to get them
and they chose to kill harry
where would can be right now he had dk
metcalf mike glorio
that's why you may be the next gm in in
new england
you know where we can be maybe brady
doesn't leave
there's a lot of scouts and gm's
answering tough questions about dk
metcalf lasting until the bottom of
round two right now
all right let's finish with a couple of
teams that have been answering a
ton of tough questions and that is our
game sunday night
philadelphia and dallas
uh the nfc's it's still anyone's
division
so here we go tony initial thoughts on
this sunday night match
well i want to see what what happens
with dallas what do we see from them
you're playing on sunday night you're
playing a division game you've been
embarrassed the last couple of weeks
what are we going to see from you just
like we saw from the san francisco 49ers
we saw a championship
heart after that debacle against miami
are we going to see that from dallas
philadelphia you got a chance to bury
your number one rival
are you going to put the dagger in i i
think this is that's what this game
comes down to to me
when i look at philly and i look at
dallas you know
we people talk about how how hard they
play dallas
they're up and down sometimes they play
tough sometimes they don't but philly
when i watch them on tape
even though they've been disappointed
they've been up and down and consistent
they still play hard you don't see guys
not hustling you don't see guys not
trying to make
the play and it's led by their defensive
front i tell you derek barnett he's been
playing a lot better since he's healthy
and he's back on the field but
philadelphia they play hard and they
play tough
and that's why what i like what they're
doing they still have their head coach
they still have
carson wins who's making some plays with
his legs i like what they're doing even
though
you know they're underachieving a little
bit if the cowboys can't get themselves
into a spot where they're even
competitive against one of their top
rivals on the road like they weren't
competitive against washington on sunday
i don't know what to say they are i
don't know if they beat the jets right
now especially if ben dinucci is the
quarterback that's one of the big
questions that's going to linger over
the week
can andy dalton be cleared to play on
sunday night if not it's ben dinucci and
garrett gilbert
and that explains why the eagles are
seven and a half point favorites guys
uh we're gonna find out on sunday nights
you guys will be
in the studio i will be in philadelphia
and we got a couple more days to decide
on our picks rodney because right now
you and i
are the nfc east of picking games
it's it's been rough we're going to turn
it around it starts this weekend
guys thanks so much for doing it thanks
man
i just i just got to stay humble man and
get back and get back focused i can't
listen to
america that's what kills me when i'm
listening to america
check out the knowledge with america
maybe this weekend it changes that
relationship maybe we need a little
break we'll see
all right guys thank you in the immortal
words of
rodney harrison from last year i hate
america
remember that one
you remember everything florida he does
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports